house correspondent peter ducey starts
us off tonight live from philadelphia
good evening peter
good evening brett the president argues
that when states made it easier to vote
early or by mail because there was a
global pandemic
that was good but that when republican
lawmakers try to limit
certain pandemic era provisions because
they say they are concerned about voter
fraud
that is historically bad
this is election subversion it's the
most
dangerous threat to voting in the
integrity of free and fair elections
in our history the president's problem
is with states hoping to
tighten election laws and require voter
id including texas
they want to make it so hard and
convenient that they hope
people don't vote at all that's what
this is about
texas republicans can't do anything
though as long as democratic colleagues
are in d.c
they got on two chartered jets
maskless with at least one case of light
beer
and about that flight away from a vote
to require
id to vote they almost surely had to
show identification to get on that jet
texas democrats insist
this is no stunt we are not here smiling
we are not spiking the ball we are not
uh saying that we are happy but there
are definitely some attempts at humor
like this lawmaker who made a
misspelled posting intended to say my
first meal as a fugitive
delicious once they hit the ground in
texas
they can be arrested and brought back to
the capitol at some time they're going
to have to return
whether whenever it is and when it is
we're going to pass this bill out of the
house again
so they may just be delaying the
inevitable we can't stay here
indefinitely to run out the clock
to stop republican anti-voter
bills vice president harris hosted the
runaway texans today
telling reuters i think they have shown
great courage and certainly great
conviction
and commitment the administration is
looking at the big picture though
condemning republicans who claim the
last election was a fraud
the big lie is just that a big lie
the truth about new federal voter
protections the president wants though
he doesn't have the votes so until then
he'll ask the department of justice to
get more involved
legislation is one tool but not the only
tool elections
have consequences and that's why the
president wants to make sure
his side stays in power just like we did
in 2020 we have to prepare for 2022.
and the president came here today to
talk about part of the oath he took
to the constitution that was signed at
independence hall right behind us
the part of the oath that talks about
defending against
threats foreign and domestic that is how
seriously he is framing the coming fight
over voting rights
brett peter ducey live in philadelphia
peter thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else